The Joe Rogan Experience why do you
think the metaverse didn't take off why
was that a colossal failure uh well it's
because it's I mean look you know the
Zuckerberg's version of the metaverse is
that none of no one has legs like
everyone looks like Nintendo Wii
characters and stuff and it's goofy
where you look at like something like VR
chat which I use we you could be
anything you want you could have a scan
of you and make it look super realistic
so when you're talking to somebody you
look like you're talking to a real
person but but like that see that's a
actually a woman that used her phone and
scanned Her Image into an avatar and it
that's the stuff that's cool and
unfortunately Zuckerberg and all those
guys have been pushing this like
ridiculous Nintendo Wii now this was to
be just so this was sucker this is
meta's right right right right right
right right but but that's the metaverse
that you know he's not selling this
metaverse right you know he's selling
this silly version of it so what's the
silly version is the fact you have to
headset could you just type in like like
you know the Oculus worlds I think yeah
or whatever this is that's the stuff
that what he's showing is more closer to
what I'm using right now and that's you
know VR chat this is see like look at
all these goofy characters like
see you have no legs you look like a
little cart it looks like for kids you
know and what you were just watching
like with that uh other image that is
coming soon or you know that's the kind
of stuff that's already out there and
and uh that I use you know I'm I could
be a realistic person I could be a
cartoon character I could be anything I
want I have legs this is just like I
don't know for kids it's very kids is
this is not the only thing that was
available right correct like this is
just to like hang out and talk to people
I guess right but this is Zuckerberg
like the metaverse this is his like
we're spending billions of dollars
thinking this kind of thing's gonna take
off and you know so here's something
that I asked someone over a year ago
that I didn't understand because we
hadn't seen the AI stuff
um
there's spaces like this where I'll try
to pull it back up on the screen when
this guy is like floating around in here
this is not how they did it I'll be
honest with you but that's how I was
explaining to me when you're when you're
in that world you could it shows like a
missile silo or something you could be
like nope don't make that a missile silo
I want to be on a beach you just say
that and I'll go okay yeah I got a beach
it's like no it's too cartoony make it
more realistic right and it'll be like
more realistic Beach and that's how some
of the metaverse stuff is supposed to be
it's not here yet though and I don't
know how long it's gonna take to get
here but but isn't a barrier to entry
just the putting on goggles that's a lot
of people don't want to do that right
well it's also makes people sick uh and
also you know a lot of problems and
that's mostly based off uh uh frame rate
uh so like if you're you're using
something that is poorly made like
software like a nap and you put it on
and it's the frame rate's [__] then
you're just gonna get sick immediately
or is it too low a frame rate yeah too
low a frame rate you start getting sick
so it just confuses you yeah it just
makes you feel like uneasy like you know
when you're spinning on a carnival ride
or something and her stomach starts
getting that makes sense where if your
mind if your eyeballs are seeing
something that's blurry and [__] your
mind might say oh my God you're sick you
should throw up exactly you ate
something bad you're dying right yeah
yeah and here's something I'll show you
it's tough there's not a lot of content
and Facebook may be [__] up by not
showing this stuff more so Canon made
this dual fish eye lens I'm pretty sure
it's the only one that's out there right
now right that allows you to shoot
content to be watched these headsets and
when it's done right which hasn't been
done right very much but when it is done
right
It's [__] amazing it is wild how cool
it looks but there's not a lot to look
at right now and you have to put the
headset on to see it right but it's
things in front of you look like you
should just Reach Out And Touch them and
they're in high definition quality it
seems like every iteration of these
things we're always waiting for the one
that's like that's it like if you go
back to when VR was first talked about
was like the 80s and 90s remember they
thought that that was going to be a
thing you put on the goggles you're in
another world but technology wasn't
really there and then all of a sudden
with oculus and with the HTC Vive okay
we're getting real close now we're
getting real close but it's still like
not quite that's what that's what they
can do yeah that's what they think apple
is going to do with their headset it
might that it's going to be that cool
supposedly so this is VR in the 90s they
probably thought this is the beginning
we're getting ready and this is this is
going to be the future to use this you
had to be in a big pod like those pods
we almost want to use now but the Pod
was just to track you like if you went
out of the pot it wasn't reading you
anything inside the Pod it read and you
had to have all sorts of cables and
wires and things connected to you still
though where did they have this at a
Cosi okay so this is in the 90s
yeah here we are 2023. it's it's still
not quite you would have thought that
would have taken off I forgot about that
that's what the guy that's what the
headset looks like
which they still have these things and
you know arcades all over the place the
graphics got a little better but one of
the things they think they're going to
be able to do is recreate psychedelic
experiences they think they're going to
be able to make a VR psychedelic
experience so you could trip balls
without having to do any drugs and it'll
have the same effect on your mind I do
it a pretty good version of it like all
the time yeah yeah the thing I play all
the time I have a character that you
could do DMT acid mushrooms and stuff
like that and you take it and you start
you start seeing a little bit of trails
on your hands and then the more you
start seeing more Trails like it's
pretty good and you can do DMT where
there's like [__] like Buddhas coming
out of the ground like like that look
like lasers and [__] yeah it's sometimes
we'll just listen to music get high and
just do that for hours
and what what what are you using what is
this looks like unreal but someone's
made of a shrimp trip yeah
oh wow this just goes on for a few
minutes yeah there's just different
visuals and stuff how many grams did you
say that yeah see oh I love that
lighting effect where it's like clouds
Shadows maybe this is a real video then
they [__] with it yeah I think this is
a real dog yeah yeah this is a real
video
the dog knows you're tripping that's
cool
so what are you using I I'm using VR
chat which is like the good version of
what Zuckerberg's trying to do and VR
chat is connected how like you're using
a PC it's free you can actually use an
Oculus for it you're not going to get
that great of Graphics but I'm using
like a really high-end PC and a valve
index headset and uh it's a VR chat's
free and it's kind of like you know you
just download it you make your character
or whatever and then you go hey I want
to go to Disneyland or hey I want to go
buy on a beach you know and you just
type in beach and it's like Google and
they'll show you all the worlds you can
go to whoa they do go there meet up with
your friends you know do acid on the
beach or whatever and the graphics are
really high-end oh yeah it's there's you
know it's it's it's each level is made
by a different person so there's like
good versions of it and bad versions of
it realistic versions of it so this is
like the real Cutting Edge yeah this is
what this is what
you know this is way more popular times
a lot you know than Zuckerberg's stuff
really and this is how many people are
using this uh it's one of the largest uh
the user base of a multiplayer game on
Steam there is another thing which I
don't like you're you're hung up on that
headset you don't maybe today you do but
you're not going to have to use the
headset you'll be able to play with me
and Brian if we have our headsets on
just through a browser like this like
you oh you can do that right now yeah
you don't have to put the headset yeah
oh so you can play it like a video game
yeah or a chat room now what is the best
version of Graphics like these things
are all made by different people right
so what's the best version so if if I
were to play this right now with you I
have bookmarked like all these worlds so
like I have the best world to go to if
you want to be in a beach best world if
you want to be on the moon best you know
so uh like look at this bar that you can
this kind of has good lighting and stuff
but you know it almost looks like a nice
realistic bar uh and look at that
character see like that's somebody that
scanned himself it looks like yeah
obviously yeah weird
and so now you look back at what we were
just watching with Zuckerberg's you know
metaverse and it's so silly compared to
this you know like graphic Wise It's
like
it could be anything in your wine yeah
but isn't the metaverse stuff the the
Zuckerberg stuff capable of doing things
like this yeah it's just it that's why
people why it's not working though like
look at that that looks like a real ice
bin for popsicles you know like at a
convenience store you know that's not
the graphics you're seeing on on
Zuckerberg Zuckerberg's it's very
cartoony very kids kind of feeling yeah
but is that for all of them or just
different software applications well
like you could play this on the headset
you know but the metaverse is the
Facebook like they're trying to get you
into that metaverse world and that's
what's failing but it's other stuff in
the metaverse like with those the Oculus
that they're hap that they have um they
have these virtual tours yeah yeah but
that's not that's not like the metaverse
that's like you can you can play the
headset's just like a computer pretty
much so you can download anything on it
you know that we're so the metaverse is
like a Walled Garden metaverse is like
what we were just watching in your chat
where it's kind of like a chat that's
the real metaverse but what what
Zuckerberg was trying to do you're
saying is like a Walled Garden like they
were making it very specific to these
apps they were going to have these kind
of cartoony things right it's it it's
the metaverse is
doing it through all these characters
and stuff like that
I don't know
it's hard to it's so hard to explain
because it's uh they made it confusing
as [__] you know but if anybody can't
explain if you can't explain it nobody
can explain right that's a lot of the
problem you know
it's vr's taking off the metaverse is
just not taken off because
Facebook wants you to live inside their
world you know and it's a world that
they create right so that's what I mean
by right yeah well yeah yeah so it's all
their stuff and it's also a very
stylistic I kind of feel like if I've
been having the problem if I haven't
come across anything yet that like Brian
and I couldn't explain or show you in
less than three minutes that they
haven't [__] figured it out yeah
exactly right we're not there yet I feel
like I'm like I don't know yeah it seems
close but it seemed close for four years
so yeah that's what I'm saying like with
every iteration of the virtual reality
world it's like this is gonna be it but
it's not it's not I don't know how much
the pandemic would have slowed down
production I feel like it did [__] up
some stuff well they were all working in
offices doing stuff messing with these
headsets because they have shown some uh
behind like uh there's a video of
Zuckerberg has I think on 60 Minutes
they were showing someone behind the
scenes prototype headsets they have a
thing that's uh it sticks out from the
head like the eye area it's ultrasonic
sound waves that are pointed at your
mouth
and the the lady that they had tried me
was a guy they said they could feel
raindrops on their on their mouth Jesus
and that was recreated with sound waves
yeah physically touching like touching
you but that's not anything they have
commercially available it's just like an
in-house demo
and that sounds [__] cool too but it
seems like it's the neural link it seems
like it's some sort of neural interface
when that that hits then all this [__]
is going to make sense and that's even
scarier because you don't know what
you're seeing as real or not you know
that's a sci-fi movie Shoot you're gonna
walk right off the top of a building
exactly yeah you get hacked somehow or
trolled and like you go into traffic you
know yeah
that's scary as [__] well I mean the
future is always going to be scary when
it comes to things like this things just
technology in general there's gonna be
some mistakes